as a human how do you know where to  drive through an intersection the lane  lines  some don't have any the road edges  that depends too the reality is every  intersection is different so how could  you hand code a policy to take the  correct path through all intersections  in short there's no way we intuitively  know where to go based on all factors of  the intersection and that's exactly what  our laneless model has learned  our latest driving model is trained on  over 1 million minutes of human driving  let's see how it does on this hill with  multiple intersections that curve and  have no lane lines  [Music]  open pilot is able to navigate both  intersections easily since we do what a  human does look at the road and decide  where to go  what kinds of things do you want to see  lameless tackle next let us know in the  comments below  [Music]